الماسك هو مكتفي يبدو بكل اللي عامله فيه
تويتر والازمه الي شاعللها مع ابل الايام
الماضيه واللي رجع على فكره وهدف فيها
شويه وكشف انه التقى رئيس ابل وحلوا سوا
اييي سوء التفاهم اللي كان صاير بينهم
وزار كمان مقر ابل ماسك يبدو كمان مو
مكتفي بالقلق اللي صاير سياسيين جوا
امريكا وحتى في مختلف دول العالم بسبب
ابتلاكه تويتر كانه كل هذا موقفا فقال
اليوم انه يطلع بشيء جديد يتصدر في
العناوين شريحه نيورولاند طيب نيورولين
الشركه الو ماسك متخصصه في علوم الاعصاب
وشرائح المخ اول مره يتكلم عنها ماسك وعلى
فكره وانتم محاكم لها همم واللي ممكن
تعمله ولكن جديد هو الاشياء اللي اكتشفها
امس في مناسبه خاصه
كانوا عازمين عليها ناس محدده طيب
قبل ما اقول لكم ايش اعلن ماسك خليني اشرح
لكم شويه عن نيك الشركه هذه اساسها ماسك
في 2016 وهدفها زراعه وصلت دماغيه لاسلكيه
بين الدماغ واجهزه كمبيوتر وعن طريق
تكنولوجيا معينه انهم يعالجوا حالات
مستعصيه وفي طموحاتهم علاج الزهايمر الخرى
في اصابات الحبل الشوكي فقدان الذاكره
والسمع والبصر والارق والغيرهم والشركه
اصدرت شريحه باسمها
على حيوانات ومن سنتين عرضتنا تجربتها على
خنزير وعلى قرد كمان الجديد اللي اعلنه في
ايفنت امسك انه خلاص الشركه قدمت معظم
الاوراق المطلوبه لهيئه الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه للحصول على الموافقات لبدء
التجارب على البشر وقال انه خلال سته اشهر
التجارب على البشر المفروض انها تبدا
والشريحه مثل مكان ماسك شرح مره من زمان
يعني بتنزرع في الجمجمه عن طريق ازاله
الجزء منها وزرع الشريحه مكانها فكره انه
تجارب البشر تبدا كمان سته اشهر امون
مفاجاه الوحيده في كلام ماسك في المفاجاه
اكثر كمان عن كلام عن التطبيقات العمليه
اللي راح تبدا فيها التجارب على البشره
ابحار
اناني
المعصوص
ستيفن هوكينج
هما مساعده المصابين باعاقات الحركه على
التواصل واستعاده البصر للمكفوفين وخلينا
نقول انه هذه الاخيره تحديدا مفاجاه للكل
كانت وتحديد اننا الاطباء والعلماء
المتخصصين في هذا المجال يعني البصره
فقدان واستعادته وعلاجه هذا مجال العلماء
بيدرسوه من مئات السنين وبيحاولوا انهم
يحلوا بعجول بعد سنوات من البحث الان جاء
مسكه وهو اللي هيحل هذا الموضوع واصلا كيف
ممكن هذا الشيء خلونا نتكلم اكثر ونفهم من
ضيفنا واللي هذا المجال واختصاص وينضم
الينا استشاري طب وجراحه العيون دكتور
محمد جندي اهلا فيك دكتور محمد هل نقدر
نقول انه فعلا ماسك ممكن يحقق هذا النوع
من اللي يعني معجزه هي يعني او خلينا نقول
اختراق كبير
اهلا وسهلا ومساكم الله بالخير
اول شيء اتمنى اتمنى ان يكون كلام صحيح
ان شاء الله كان بالنسبه للعين كانت
بالنسبه للامراض العصبيه او اي مرض بالجسم
فبصراحه كده حيحلنا مشاكل العالم الحمد
لله وهذا الشيء نحن كلنا نبغاه الحمد لله
الامراض دي تشفى منها
لكن خلينا نفكر بالمنطقيه بسيطه يعني لا
ندخل في تفاصيل الموضوع استعاده البصر
وشخص ما قد شاف قبل كده يرجع يشوف خلينا
شبهلك الموضوع بمثال بسيط خلينا نقول شخص
مثلا طلع وقال انا ممكن اجيب شريحه او
اجيب لكم دواء همم يمنع الموت طيب كلام
جميل لكن خلينا نفكر الموت والوفاء لها
سبب جدا جدا
يعني لو تطبق هذا الكلام على العين اسباب
العمى على العين جدا كثيره بتتكلم عن مثلا
قرنيه العين بتتكلم عن عصب العين شبكيه
العين بعدين العصب اللي ياخذ الصوره من
العين الى الدماغ وبعدين الدماغ اللي راح
يترجم الصوره هذه عشان انت تشوفها فهو
بيتكلم عن اي عمو بالضبط فيها لانه انواع
العمل فيها جدا جدا مختلفه يعني
ما وضحوا يعني
هذا الكلام يقدر يخلينا نقول انه همم لسه
هم بيشتغلوا على تطوير الموضوع ولا انه
كلامهم لا هو لامي واقرب لانه الترويج
الزائر
اممم التلوجه السائله ما توقع يعني شخصيه
زي اول ماسكه كده وما شاء الله بيعمل
اشياء جدا كبيره المفروض هو بيقول حاجه
يعني حتى لو انها كان حاجه في المستقبل
البعيد او القريب ان شاء الله يا رب يا رب
انها تكون صحيحه يعني وان تكون على قدر
الشيء هذا يعني نحن بنلعب على مصداق
اكيد لكن حكايه انه مثلا في شريحه ممكن
نزرعها في العين تخلي الشخص مثلا يشوفن
يتحسن النظر ويخلينا نقول هذا الشيء ترى
موجود
على البشر بالشكل الكبير انه مثلا في
امراض معينه اللي مثلا تصيب الشبكيه يكون
في الشبكيه فالشخص الواحد مثلا زي الشريحه
في الشبكيه للعين بعد كده النظر عند الشخص
راح يتحسن بدرجه جدا بسيطا نتكلم عن مثلا
5%10% شيء يخلينا نقول انه ما كان يشوف
لكن صار يشوف اضاءه عشان يشوف حركه بسيطه
هل هذه النظر يقدر يخليه يمارس حياته يروح
ويجيء زي ما بيقول انه يجي عندي انسان
مضحك جدا وهو بيتكلم حتى انه بيقول انه
الناس اللي مولودين حتى مكفوفين طيب خليني
اقول لك حاجه بس اذكرها او في او بيانات
اللي طلعت عن التجارب اللي عملوها واحنا
من الاشياء اللي قالوها انه همم القرود
اللي تعرضوا لهذه الشريحه
تعالوا من تعب ومرض وما الى ذلك طيب الان
اذا هم اتعبوا من هذا الشيء هل هذا الشيء
برده يقدر يخلي الاف دي اي او اداره
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه توافق على انه
يتم تجربه الموضوع على الانسان
وحقيقه جابت نتيجه لهم ايش نوع المرض اللي
كان عندهم وهم بالشريحه هذه عالج المرض
هذا كل الموضوع هيكون يعني واضح للكل يعني
حتى هتكون مصداقيه عنده اعلى همم لكن ما
نقدر زي ما قلنا يعني الموضوع بشكل كبير
يسعدك
احنا في التجربه خلى انه مثلا قرد يعزف
وما الى ذلك بس انه كانت النتيجه
فايش معايير الاف دي ايه عشان يقبلوا انه
ننتقل لمرحله البشر
طبعا اول شيء انه يثبته انه هذا الشيء ما
هو مضر ما هو مضر لا للقرده والحكم مضر
للانسان هذا مرحله اولى والمرحله الثانيه
يثبت انه هذا الشيخ حقيقي مفيد كان
الحيوانات يعني امن ومفيد وبعد كده ممكن
يدخل مرحله تطبيق وعلى البشر في اجزاء
معينه في حالات معينه طبعا تحت اشراف
تركيز كبير
يعني بتقنيه لو تحققت حتى تكون رائعه جدا
فان شاء الله انها تتحقق وبنشكرك على هذه
التوزيعات كان معنا استشاري طب هو جراحه
العيون دكتور محمد جوجل شكرا لك